[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
it is time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i
mom explain it all clark county school
students went back to school today
and for many it is the first time back
in the classroom in a year and a half
and a new study from parents magazine
looked at the hardest parts for
of school for kids last year and as you
may have guessed missing their friends
was number one missing friends staying
focused and worrying about the pandemic
were the top
challenges kids faced in school last
year wearing a mask and getting
one-on-one attention from their teacher
also ranked high
the number one thing parents are worried
about as the kids head back to school
this year
is if they have forgotten how to
socialize but they're still
more than ready for them to get back out
there the top thing parents say they're
excited for us
for this school year it's getting their
kids back
into social settings up next if you're
having trouble sleeping you are not
alone and science says there are a lot
of good reasons to take a short nap
a 10 to 20 minute power nap is the ideal
length to bring benefits including
feeling instantly happier a new study
from bmg
journals finds that people who nap twice
a week were 48 percent less at risk of
having a heart attack
stroke or heart failure and finally
speaking of naps have you heard of a
nappuccino
it's essentially a nap with a caffeine
kick a nappuccino is when you drink a
cup of coffee
just before falling asleep for about 10
to 20 minutes
that's roughly equivalent to the
duration it takes for the caffeine to
really set in
then when you're waking up you're both
refreshed by the nap
but also revitalized by a sudden burst
of energy brought on by the coffee that
is now in your system
sounds like a nice little calf nap and
now you've had a momsplaining